GAME ONE OF 82.
THE SEASONING IN.
DANCING TOWARDS THE NET, AND CE.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT
PLAY.HERE!
DEMKO THE PAD SAVE.
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY.
HE HAS TIME AND SPACE.
DEMKO GOT A
FLUTTERING WAS THE PUCK NEAR
MIKE SMITH.
AND NOW RATHBONE KEEPS PASS AHE!
DRAISAITL HAS IT. WEIRD BOUNCE.
THE PUCK ALL THE WAY DOWN THE
ICE.NGING IT
SEEN 18 SHOTS ON GOAL
CUMULATIVELY HERE BETWEEN T
McDAVID TO NURSE.
SHOOOOGOES TO WORK.
FINDS NURSE DRIVING TO THE NET
AND PULJUJARVI WITH THE BIG BODY
PUCK AND NOW THE CANUCKS ARE
KEITH AND HOW HIS
SKATING ABILITY ALLOWED HIM TO
PICKED OFF A MIKE SMITH PASS.
THE CANUCKS TRYING TO POUNCE ON
HUGHES TRYING TO MAKE THE M
TYSON BARRIE UP THE LINE.
OVER TOT TARGET
HE'LL HIT IT A LOT OF T T IT.
ZACH HYMAN USING HIS SPEED.
DRIVING TO THE NET ON THE
BACKHAND.
SLOT TRYING TO GET INTO THE
LANE.
J.T. MILLER THROUGH THE NEUTRAL
ZONE.
CARRIES THE PUCK IN.
HOGLANDER
LITTLE FLYBY BY PETTERSSON AND .
HORVAT, PEARSON, AND END ACTION.
ALMOST CAME ON TO THE ICE.
QUICKLY REALIZED WHAT WAS GOING
ON. THE ZONE. WILL SHOOT.
HE CAN'T SHOOT IN THE SHOOTOUT,
THAT WAS MY MISTAKE, SINGER.OAL!
>> Louie: WHAT A FIST PUMP.
HE WAS PUMPED UP FOR THAT ONE
THERE.naryan: TANNER PEARSON
LOOKING TO ANSWER FOR THE
CANUCKS.